William Lee Miller if James Madison were
alive today and sitting here with us
what would he think about what's going
on in this country well he'd have a lot
of thoughts that what we all did was
impute to these others the things we are
telling you and I could say he deplore
this and important thing though I'm more
important than all the criticisms he
might make of our situation today would
be he would say 200 plus years and it's
still here Constitution he was a chief
figure in writing the ideas he had
underneath that Constitution the main
thing or a main thing at least he was
worried about was making it last and it
has lasted you know it was already a big
deal to go all the way from Maine and
New Hampshire to Georgia looked awfully
big 13 colonies bring those all together
make a system that would work Republic's
before having worked they lasted only a
short time preoccupied with that they
fell apart
this one hasn't fallen apart slavery was
still institution abolish slavery kept
the Union together became the world's
most prosperous and powerful nation 200
plus years later under the same
Constitution so that would be point one
before you got to all the things he'd
criticize but you might we might guess
he would criticize would be that what he
wanted to bring off and has happened let
me ask you before and I've got a lot of
other questions about today versus other
things you got there yeah let me ask you
about him who was he can you describe
him to us what he looked like what he
sounded like how big he was short very
short and some journalists came said
what I really want to know is how short
well I don't know five three sure the
Virginians tended to be tall the other
one the Virginians came in to
Philadelphia they were these impressive
fellows and their horses and they little
New Englanders would be quite impressed
but Madison not the great little Madison
was tagged he got because he was short
and and slight didn't have it wouldn't
have worked in many other times of
American politics probably including
today couldn't hear him beyond the
go in the room he's talking in didn't
have Patrick Henry and these orders
would just outdo him all together but he
was the best prepared he knew what he
was talking about they knew he knew what
he was talking about so they would
gather round and they listened and he
would get to the nub of the matter he
was a bright son of a Virginia a
plantation owner who was sent north to
college
usually Jefferson went to William and
Mary usually somebody from that
background to go over to William and
Mary on the Eastern Shore on the
Tidewater of Virginia but one of the
tutors said try this College of New
Jersey as this new president come over
from Scotland and it's got a lot of new
ideas they're about republicanism so he
did go and he he loved it he learned at
Princeton was important College of New
Jersey was very important to Madison
State on a little our first graduate
student to make it to the to the White
House so to speak what President was he
he was the fourth brother what years 18
9 to 18 16 17 whatever eight years yeah
how long did he live he lived until 1836
he was the last of the father's is a
good good book about the end of his life
which my book is just about one little
period when he's young the end of his
life called the last of the fathers and
Jefferson and Adams had died in 1826
with this phenomenal thing that people
can't believe actually happened that
they both died on the fiftieth
anniversary of the Declaration
independence while I use for the end of
this book ten years later
Madison's in his mid-80s and he's
failing and it's June and it's getting
toward the end of June and some of his
friends say you know can't we get some
stimulants and keep him alive till it
took July fourth the sixtieth
anniversary that declaration
independence Madison says no thanks he
said he dies a week early
he's never won for dramatic jesters you
even start off by writing what we that
live anybody that the country can do
this with those of us that live here in
Washington could just drive an hour and
15 minutes down the road and be at his
home in Orange Orange County Orange
County appeal you earlier right did he
actually live at Mount Pierre yes he
grew up there and he came back there his
his life is framed by Montpelier there
was a period about the period when I'm
writing about him in his 30s which is
the most important part of his life I
just write about about five years of his
life but were those five or 18-hole if
you say five it's 18 1784 to 1790 the
most important are 1786 just before
you're getting to the connect the
federal Convention in 1787 when you're
getting ready to go to the federal
convention that writes the constitution
writing things preparing being the most
studious thinking about it making memos
to himself going to the Annapolis
convention which people remember from
their textbooks precedes the invention
of writing letters to his friends with
the ideas that he's going to present
there and then after the can being the
most important probably the most
important single person at the federal
convention you can get an argument about
that but I not much most people would
agree with that then afterward in the
fight to get it ratified joining with
Hamilton invites him to be the first New
Yorker not to be the person who wasn't a
New Yorker could be invited to write
these essays his op-ed page pieces
defending the Constitution Luciano's
Federalist Papers through 17 through
that next winter then going to the
Virginia ratifying convention it had to
have Virginia or the thing wouldn't have
worked that's another big thing then
going to the first Congress as a
congressman and out of the promises he's
made getting the being leader in getting
the Bill of Rights at it that's a period
of let's say five years which is really
nothing he did even though he was
present you knighted States and
Secretary of State and very important in
other ways one of the founders of the
Democratic Party with Jefferson in the
1790s
none of those other things was important
as important as what he did in those
years and so I take those out and
feature them you uh you and there's lots
of words that are thrown around in the
book that I want you to define if you
could force you've done it in the last
couple minutes for instance when you say
republicanism is that Republican Party
ISM no well it's not the Republican
Party that's begins with Abraham Lincoln
in the begins in the 1850s that's a long
that's much later but these words are
around Democratic Republican not
democratic in a favorable sense yet but
Republican is the word that they would
all use for the kind of government
they're setting up and they look back to
Greece to the the city-states and Italy
to Switzerland Republic in Geneva to all
the history of Republic's which is a
kind of government that doesn't have a
monarch doesn't have what is
republicanism is a is a tricky thing
twice in the Federalist Papers Madison
tries to describe what it is he's got a
problem about the existence of slavery
in this country in relation to
republicanism but it's the name it's
it's the equivalent of our saying
democracy we know that describes the
kind of government we endorse even
though we'd have a bit of an argument
about is this democracy what's the
essence of it can it include that they
were in that situation with respect to
republicanism what about the word
democracy is this a democracy is this
now yes well democra democracy in my
view there are people today who would
set those two words over against each
other I wouldn't do that I think what
James Madison endorsed as republicanism
and Jefferson did and the other of the
others did George Washington did very
important that he did military leader
endorsed republicanism subordinated the
military to the legislative body that
that segue did that the way you
pronounce that word that our former
president used to use I learned it from
Ronald Reagan using it to them he segue
it segues into democracy it shifts
modulates into democracy and come
down to us today that's the way I would
say it the wants you have a broader
electorate and you begin to talk about
the demos of people in a more insistent
way you call it Democritus and the rest
of them are talking about which they see
going all the way back to Athens this a
little bit off the subject but all these
terms that we use today like a Democrat
and a Republican and you refer back then
in the early days to Tories and Whigs
and all that when when did today's
Democratic Party or the Democrats and
today's Republican party Republicans
when were they established well the the
Republicans are you can say it's easy
they're established in 1854 let's say in
1850s as the fight over slavery slavery
in the territories comes to be the
dominant issue and the anti Nebraska
party that is against the bills about
Kansas and Nebraska which had to do with
the slavery in the territories were the
Republicans and they combined pieces of
the old wigs and so forth that's a later
story from the one in this book
Republicans in this the political
scientist talk about the third party
system and that's what we have now
Republicans beginning in 1854 and the
Democrats there's a middle part where
the Whigs are the party who oppose the
the Democrats the Democrats go back to
Madison and Jefferson and particularly
to Jefferson's winning in 1800 and
Somoza Quarles in the 1790s between
Jefferson and Hamilton Jefferson Madison
on one side Hamilton and John Adams not
exactly allied with Hamilton on the
other side who were the Federalists they
fed the Federalist fade away it's a
period of confusion then you get a
second party system the Whigs and the
Democrats and you get the Republicans
and Democrats down today it's a Tory
Tory goes back to England of course is a
supporter of the the king and he's a
high conservative of a British type and
Tories we use in in those days you'd use
it also for somebody who opposed
independence Mundus continued British
America loyal to the king
and then you mentioned Federalists
before we go on what's the difference
between a Federalist and anti-federalist
well that anti-federalists is an
opponent of the Constitution that was
written in Philadelphia in 1787 a
federalist at that point is a proponent
Madison is a federalist at that moment
probably it's better to spell that with
a small F because Madison wants this
Constitution to be an A to be enacted to
be ratified in to begin the
anti-federalists were Patrick Henry
George Mason others who opposed it
why were they opposed to the
Constitution well opponents can combine
lots of reasons even contradictory ones
so you had people they tended to be more
local istic they were more attached to
Virginia more attached to Pennsylvania
more attached to Massachusetts they
didn't like things in these other they
didn't want to be united with these
others they had local stage Patrick
Henry was a big shot in Virginia they're
suspicious of central power this looked
like a big new central government that
they're bringing into being in this
constitution they also the thing that
they the point that they won their
strongest point was they wanted a
written Bill of Rights and Madison was a
leader among those who said ok you vote
to ratify the Constitution we promise we
will we will enact a written Bill of
Rights and they did first Congress comes
Madison is the leader in getting a bill
of rights added to the Constitution he
didn't want the desire for a Bill of
Rights to be used to scuttle the whole
Constitution there were those who said
you know this Constitution is no good
let's start all over let's have a new
convention Madison even though there
were things he didn't like about the
Constitution he said that souffle isn't
gonna rise twice I mean to have another
convention is chaos and get all these
people with all these objections again
that we brought it off in Philadelphia
was well he used the word miracle lots
of people have used the word miracle
about what happened in the summer of
1787 until Adelphia that ain't going to
happen again and so let's ratify it and
get it in motion then we'll add the Bill
of Rights and don't
use that to undercut the Constitution
Patrick Henry wanted the Bill of Rights
which included taking the to power to
tax away from this Newcomen well that's
undercutting the government altogether
that's going back to what he wanted in
the first places and anti-federalist he
didn't want us strong central government
he wanted a sovereign Virginia in effect
William Lee Miller is a professor where
I'm a professor at the University of
Virginia founded by Thomas Jefferson
first President of the Board James
Madison in Charlottesville when did you
first get interested in writing this
particular book I wrote a book about
religious liberty in the early days and
in Virginia and that was one stream
about two six seven years ago and then I
was examining the moral foundations of
American government which is one of my
topics and I said this period of what
this man did is telling the story is a
way to get out that topic so and I'm
more and more impressed with Madison the
papers are now beautifully available
printed full edition you can read it's
they're easier to get at than they used
to be where are they they're in well you
can get them in any good library the
papers of James Madison the volumes
eight nine ten will have these memos
that I that he writes to himself where
he's thinking his stuff out nicely noted
telling identifying these things like
we've just been talking about but the
point was those years we've identified I
said that's the time when you're going
to pick one man which you should do as a
American was collaborative American
thing was collaborative and Madison said
it was collaborative said it should be
it's better we don't have any soul on or
like Kyrgyz any of these guys of the
Greek books who were one great lawmaker
we had a group but if you had one most
important among the group for the
Constitution it was Madison himself and
so he those are the years when he
thought this through and that's that's
the story I tell in that book where are
you from arisen I'm from the west from
Wyoming Colorado in Nebraska Kansas
where'd you grow up
Wyoming first Laramie Wyoming then in
Kansas then went to University of
Nebraska got lots of ties to call
righto and toning down to the present my
family whoops on my family live in
Colorado where you what are your degrees
in I have a Navy from University of
Nebraska two degrees from Yale B D and a
PhD all in history no not in history I'm
not an historian I'm a political ethics
my present title is a professor of
ethics and institutions which is doesn't
fit in a department but it's a it fits
me how long have you been at the
University of Virginia ten years is it
it I think you referred to in your book
is it a special feeling to be writing a
book like this at the University of
Virginia and if so why and what else is
around you that you can tap into and we
have history yes it is a special feeling
the ethos of mr. Jefferson as they call
him in Charlottesville this is all over
the place sometimes some people think it
even gets a bit much I was taking a
young applicant for a position in a
department of which I was a chair around
at the end of his tour he pointed to a
building he said was that also designed
by mr. what's-his-name
meaning Jefferson buddy Jefferson's the
aura of Jefferson is all around because
he was not just a thinker and a
political leader he was an architect so
your your teaching in the on the grounds
that he designed and Madison is 30 miles
away at Montpelier and is related to all
of this I had an office in the library
there where the papers of James Madison
were on one side and the papers of
George Washington were on the other and
do mom alone the great Jefferson scholar
had his office down the hall sort of the
whole spirit of the nation's Virginia
beginnings are all around you that's one
of the reasons I got into this actually
it was being at this university and
having a feel for this particular
history do you find students interested
in this when they go does it take on
special again for them as but I think so
there are of course Jefferson societies
and the different groups that have there
they have a pilgrimage every year on his
birthday up to Monticello Monticello I
didn't mention that Monticello if you
don't know Jefferson Monticello
right there tourists of course coming
from all over the world to see the
things of Jefferson yes I think it means
a lot to students and they're in a
they're in the rooms on the lawn that
are designed all that's designed the
Academical village the Jefferson
designed to be a ideal University and
speakers every speaker who comes from
President Bush to Brian lamb will quote
Thomas Jefferson when you appear at the
University of Virginia which again gets
to be a bit much but nevertheless it's a
good thing
why not James Madison I don't think well
it was all was ever thus and he's always
second he's always kind of a second
place to Jefferson but not in the 1780s
because Jefferson was in Paris and all
the time that I'm telling about
Jefferson's off stage Jefferson's over
in Paris and Madison is doing what I'm
telling him out in there sinking through
the foundations of this government now
that's the second the second round you'd
had the revolution but most revolutions
devour themselves devour their children
in this case you had these able people
with Madison in the lead children of the
revolution saying let's build
institutions on the basis of the
revolution that will last what Madison
he he ought to be more honored than he
is I think well he's in a good period
again as a good deal of talk about
Madison right now you write on page 224
Madison's clear statement calls to mind
the formulation of Reinhold Niebuhr
20th century American theologian and
political thinker a formulation that is
quoted so often that in the circles in
which he is known to as to have become a
cliche it goes like this man's capacity
for justice makes democracy possible
man's inclination to injustice makes
democracy necessary who was Reinhold
Niebuhr
Reinhold Niebuhr was the greatest
well let's put it in the largest way and
then if you make me do it I'll take it
back the greatest American political
thinker of the 20th century Hans
Morgenthau the
another political scientist said he was
the greatest American since John C
Calhoun political thinker he was the
leading I guess you now say was
Protestant theologian but theologian
only in a loose sense because politics
was his main interest and through this
through the middle of this century his
role in leading the argument about
American and joining in the resistance
to Hitler his argument after the after
World War two about the pattern of
responsibilities of phrase at Dean
Acheson picked up the Secretary of State
then from neighbor about the whole
shaping of the role of the United States
which is just the chapter which is just
concluded at 45 years or from 47 roughly
until 89 91 the things we've just seen
happen in Eastern Europe and in Russia
that whole history a George cannon whose
name would be known a great diploma test
once said I know Lieber is the father of
us all that is of us realists moral
purpose but realistic political thinking
shaping America's role did you know him
anyway I certainly did he was a big
influence on me the reason I studied
things I did and he's my he'd be my
mentor my chief mentor where well
indirectly I didn't study directly with
him I studied at Yale under his brother
a man called Richard neighbor who was
kind of the Mycroft Holmes to his
Sherlock Holmes
you know the Sherlock Holmes story the
one who's in the background is even
smarter than his well-known brother but
Ronald was down in New York and we were
in we collaborated in many organizations
I wrote for his magazine I knew him in
various of Ford Foundation things and
William in Santa Barbara
for a while when did he die died in 71
again let me quote this back the his
statement man's capacity for justice
makes democracy possible man's
inclination to end justice makes
democracy necessary what I mean Madison
wrote about the injustice thing a lot I
mean yeah did he anticipate what this
but human beings live a life yes I think
when I read Madison having been much
influenced by neighbor that sentence you
just read leaps out of the pages of the
Federalist Papers and it's got two parts
it's realistic about humankind one of
the things you found out Madison we've
been through the Revolution he's only 25
when the revolution is over he's not one
of the he's not part of the big show of
76 except minor way then he comes on
stage he's sent to the Continental
Congress in Philadelphia by Virginia he
sees the way that Congress did behaves
the way the state governments the newly
instituted state governments independent
are behaving and he said you know that
picture that some people had that we
would be a Christian Sparta where people
would sacrifice their individual good to
the public good that ain't going to
happen it isn't happening what we're
seeing instead is a more mixed thing
where people are looking out for their
own interests and where power and
interest are still a very important part
in the the the thing that Madison did
that the revolutionaries of the French
Revolution and the Bolshevik Revolution
and other revolution sense didn't do he
saw that after the Revolution there
wouldn't be a new humanity human beings
would still be the way they were before
the Revolution so let's think how we can
make the ideals last without assuming
there's a transformation of humankind so
so is realistic human beings are going
to have self interests but not as
realistic or is exclusively realistic
pessimistic about humankind as
Machiavelli is that is the European
thinkers of that stripe of Machiavelli
Hobbes the great thinkers who endorsed
monarchy who saw you had to have us you
have an authoritarian government because
of human
because of himself love what did that
you mentioned several times the Prince
Machiavelli yeah
I say Madison and Machiavelli are quite
different but but the reason I bring it
up is one to ask you what James Madison
what did he study before he got ready
for the Convention in 1787 lots of books
Jefferson over in Paris sent him these
boxes that's one of the touching stories
about America's beginning these two
bright young Virginians intellectuals
that's called although practical
intellectuals and in Jefferson over in
Paris they made a kind of a deal you
look after my nephews education I'll
send you books and Jefferson sends them
in these boxes on the ships of that day
and they go out to Orange County there's
no library near Orange County Virginia
Orange County Virginia not named for
oranges named for the William of Orange
and he sits there with these books which
include a histories of the Republic's he
said I want story on books about the
history of Republic's and and he read
those he read David Hume we know is a
quite specific borrowing from the great
Scottish enlightenment thinker David
Hume but he read widely he was eclectic
I think you'd be hard-put to say here's
one thinker who influenced him but the
fact that he read a lot and studied and
made these notes both thinkers and also
constitutions and histories you know how
did it work out in this Republic in that
Republic with this question why did it
fail it was a kind of revolutionary who
who doesn't ask that question let's say
revolutionaries it's all roses and
moonbeams you know it's not white famine
a revolution your Revolution Myra we're
going to have we're going to overthrow
these Rascals who are now ruling and
then there's going to be a new new world
a new humanity so they don't ask the
hard questions about what it's going to
be like really and how you're going to
make it last
that's a part of what's distinctive
about Madison and by extension the
American Revolution they did on the
second round in the second round they
did ask those questions and say this
this things aren't transformed utterly
people are still pretty much the way
they were before
let's think of the kinds of institutions
that will
make it laugh so in in 1992 people will
be sitting somewhere and doing a
television program about the book that
describes a successful constitutional
arrangement so they were realistic and
he studied these republics of the past
and he studied the states to ask about
the vices and what's wrong why didn't
they work instead of instead of covering
it all over with with idealism and
slogans you very analytically carefully
not cynically not cynically but
analytically not but name some of those
vices you're talking about
well the overriding vice is that you
don't have enough strength at the center
to make the government function and you
had you had this double problem Liberty
you want you don't want a government
that dominates life tyranny despotism
tyrannies one poll but you also have to
have a government functions it does the
things that government have to do and
it's easy to well it's easy to have kind
of an anarchy or imagine it anyway or
authoritarian government Leviathan but
how do you put the two things together
have effective government on a large
scale on just a city-state not just face
to face but lots and lots of people over
big territory effective government doing
all the things that government needs to
do and preserve liberty that was
Madison's problem and he was really the
best thinker about that we start out
this way let's go back to it if you can
for just a little bit
James Madison sitting right here with us
and we asked him we got 27 amendments to
the Constitution today when he was on
this earth how many were there twelve
thirteen words well to just beat it well
yes the the eleventh and twelfth would
be added still while he's alive what
would he think if he looked at from 12
all the way up to 27 well I think he'd
be he wouldn't be as shocked as your
question they imply that is that that it
would be amendable was one of the things
he insisted on the French made the
mistake that their constitution wasn't
to be amended the Articles of
Confederation couldn't be amended they
thought they'd achieved perfection
Madison knew this wasn't perfect in fact
he led the fight to get the first ten
amendments right away
amending the minute you got it there so
he wouldn't be shocked by the fact that
there are that many amendments or it
would might be some of them who knows he
would agree with it he would disagree
with but the fact that it's amendment
wouldn't shock him
well would he think the fact that the
Senate instead of being selected by the
legislators in the state states is are
selected by the people directly well
let's say that he'd approve I mean he
wanted he wanted them more popular base
he and James Wilson his chief
collaborator there they they wouldn't
object I don't think they would object
to that what would he think of the
Supreme Court and the power it's gone I
don't think he would object to that of
course Hamilton certainly wouldn't
that's his collaborator in the
Federalist Papers in federal 78 is
giving the first nugget of the idea of
judicial review and role of the court
and part of what you want is that
balance you want a court that's got its
role and a Congress it's got its Rea
along come back to ask me more about
Congress and you invent this new office
not in Republic's before in quite this
way the president the executive and you
strengthen that executive when you're
worried about the base of the Congress
but you want all three of them and
you've read some things in some of these
books Montesquieu and others you're
supposed to have separation of powers
and these balances and this theory about
human nature that you aren't you aren't
going to have when people say
enlightened statesmen will solve the
problem he says you aren't always going
to have enlightened statesmen how do you
keep it going for 200 years when oh and
a half year leaders and more our
mediocrities are not enlightened or
unenlightened and then realistically
that's a situation what would he think
of the term limit movement on members of
Congress well I'm I'm the temptation is
give my opinion which which is negative
but I don't know what James Madison
would he him he had he did oppose the
anti-federalists excessive desire for
overturning they said were annual
elections and and tyranny begins they
wanted a real constant turnover and
Madison did have a sense that being a
legislator was
serious business it took some time and
at least in his terms he was on another
side from those who were the term limits
types if we may if I may that's really
cheating to relate that argument to this
one but he did have an argument which he
said no they need two years in the
Congress in six years in the Senate what
would he think of two only two political
parties the Republicans and the
Democrats well I think the he didn't
anticipate parties
none of these original founders did that
is in the 1780s they didn't when they
shape he wants them they didn't want
them I guess that's right to say they
didn't want them although then Madison
becomes in the 1790s de-facto one of the
founders of the two parties we have to
this day the one that's lasted from that
time I would say the two-party system is
a corollary and a growth out of
principles at Madison discovered about
the group basis of politics about the
fact that people differ and are going to
keep on differing that's the thing to
remember you believe in government by
the people but you also believe people
differ and we'll keep on differing that
isn't going to stop they aren't going to
have one will over in France they sort
of think it's going to be Rousseau
you're gonna have one will whole people
except for a few people over here and
you're going to call em sort of non
people or something rule them out he
knew they're going to be differences so
the two-party system is a good way to
organize the fact that you're going to
keep on having differences Plus that you
want effective government so effective
government and people differing organize
it somehow by chance part or whatever
you say by history the two-party system
evolved from elements that Madison began
I think I think I could write a thing
about Who I am and why Madison would
endorse a two-party system what would he
think of this presidential race well I
think the and the reasons for the third
party ever the third you know most
mentioned candidate Ross Perot I've
already said that he would be most
impressed favorably that it's lasted
okay now we're going to talk about some
things you might disapprove of as I
would guess I think there would be
things in the overwhelming disapproval
of Congress and in the endorsement of
Perot that would worry him because
remember these American founders very
much Madison were creatures of Congress
and believed in it they believed in the
legislative body that's where the core
of republicanism was they didn't have a
president in their minds till they till
later with the whole heritage from well
Tom Paine would say throw away the king
and the Lords and have the House of
Commons and that's the republican
government were endorsing and their
state like their their their colonial
legislatures to which they were attached
for 150 years that's where they learn
this kind of government they're setting
up and the legislature with its
principle of mutual deliberation
representative government elect
representatives they sit somewhere and
debate and they argue and they change
their minds and they say I won't go that
far that that's the that's the way a
republic makes up its mind so
representative government in a
legislature they were all legislators
Hamilton even George Washington more
than you think of him as a general he
was also sitting in legislatures Thomas
Jefferson was he wasn't just issuing
grand statements he was also and that
was at the center of republican
government and i think in the current
hostility to congress and you can
criticize particular congressmen and you
can criticize the performance of a
particular congress and criticize side
issues like how they get their checks
cast but if your criticism goes to the
point of d legitimizing the institution
of saying missing the point what's the
principle of congress what is that and
you no longer see that that's at the
core of the kind of government that we
set up that madison helped to form 200
years ago then i think you worry
and if ross perot represents that as
some of the things he says seem to me to
do i mean pushing buttons electronic
buttons and they said no that's not this
this was deliberative mutual
deliberation you have to somewhere where
you've the other side of that quote
from neighbor that you read which is
also Madison you have to balance your
interest in my interest which are
opposed somehow brought together so we
have a common life but also we have a
capacity for justice I have limited
though it may be I have some ability to
see your interest your justice to your
cause even when it's against my own so
that that will work and part of the way
you do that is to have time enough for
people to sit together and argue
deliberate discuss a representative body
arguing the people having their
petitions their remonstrance 'as the
campaigns ought to have substance so
that's part of the argument that's the
process by which a a republic or a
democracy works and short-circuiting
that in the age age of this new medium
we're now performing on it does endanger
some of the principles of the age of
print and of representative government
of madison represented Federalist Papers
you mentioned earlier and you talked a
lot about Federalist number 10 before we
get to that op-ed pieces in a short in a
bunch of New York newspapers they were
in several different newspapers Hamilton
organized the whole thing is energetic
brilliant young fellow from the West
Indies Alexander Hamilton and he first
he gets these other New York people that
gets John Jay got somebody else who
flunks out then he gets his collaborator
we think of Jefferson and Madison as
collaborators but for this period
Hamilton and Jeffrey Hamilton Madison
were collaborators they write these
things at astonishing speed if you've
tried to write things as fast as three
3,000 words a piece three a week that's
that's a lot of writing now they did
draw on some things they had on the
drawer in the drawer but it's a
tremendous
through the winter of 787 288 1787 Sony
they turned those out from November to
March this whole set of 85 papers it's a
tremendous achievement and well it's
often been said the best political
statement yet written by
is that that collection of papers you
can't go on a bookstore without seeing a
paperback collection of the Federalist
Papers are they hard to read no the
average actually they're not hard to
read they're not hard to read they're
there in a kind of 18th century style so
give yourself time to get used to them
they referred for Madison read ten you
can skip some four for Madison read ten
fourteen thirty-seven 51 you can skip
some of the arguments about why you have
this size of a house and some other
things and eighteen to twenty tell you
stuff out of his memos about old
republics of the past that you don't
need to read so you need to have
somebody say which ones to read how many
did he write at the eighty-five what's
the number good deal fewer than Hamilton
I remember John Jay wrote six John Jay
wrote it six is right I think he John
Jay wrote five and then one he got sick
Jay got sick and so it's basically
Hamilton and Jefferson for a while there
was a hammer and Madison for a while
there was a dispute about some of them
but that's all resolved if you if you
get an addition that has a question mark
or has Hamilton or Madison get a new
addition because that's an old one
because now that the scholars have
resolved on land and they were signed
what when you're Bleus you sign it you
know they signed these things with these
Latin names and they signed it Publius
so you didn't know reading it in a New
York newspaper who it was written by did
it work is that with me they credit the
Federalist Papers were getting the
Constitution passed in New York had it
had its influence not only in New York
because once they were in New York you
then we sent him around so you used him
in Virginia and in the other states that
were still half the states about it
already ratified but the states where it
was still an issue in the big states
were they're difficult ones and the
important ones and they yes I think they
had an influence there couple things
that I wanted to that you wrote I wanted
to ask you more about Alexander Hamilton
who wrote the those sentences in the
first Federalist Papers was perhaps the
most brilliant was he not question mark
you asked of the major American founders
where do you get well just from reading
them do you you know you
you've read about founding fathers at
Hamilton unlike the others had no family
base he came you know he's out of
nowhere and he gets a sponsor this
Presbyterian preacher out Caribbean
island who says hey is a bright kid it
helps him get to the mainland and get to
college and then he's brighter than all
these professors which is hard to take
for that happens and in a right he's 19
he's writing pamphlets in the pamphlet
war at the time so you had a 19 year old
now participating in the presidential
year an argument today and George
Washington recognizes how able he is and
Hamlin's one of the few who doesn't
really have all that much respect for
Washington at least intellectually
everybody else General General George
Washington was he at was he one of the
55 at the keynesian come yes but he left
what it was he he came he was a New York
delegate he was outvoted by the other
two so New York's States vote always
went the opposite or often went the
opposite of what he wanted he gave one
long speech which was very high Tory to
use the word we talked about before not
high Tory wasn't that but it was he
wanted something very close to House of
Lords life tenure things that wouldn't
have sold at all his speech though long
and a guest brilliant didn't go anywhere
and he left picked up his marbles and
went home well he left anyway let's not
say why exactly but then he came back in
after it was done to this great work of
leading the Federalist Papers yeah he
was brilliant and but and Madison was
very smart too these are very able
people United States was very lucky to
have people is able right there at the
spot in this fortunate moment but you do
say this though and early in the book
you say but James Madison was not so
great a president that's right Adam you
don't want me to go into his presidency
and I'm not prepared to do it exactly he
you were in the problem of the war the
war of 1812 and diplomatic problems he
his great work is what I described in
this book and he's actually I think you
could say the four first presidents all
had something other than their
presidency that was more important than
their president and those four were were
Washington John Adams we
would be the Atlas of Independence in
1777 and James Madison
now the Bellamy 20th Center up the only
20th century person you might say that
up would be Dwight Eisenhower you could
say Dwight Eisenhower had something
other other than and before he was
president that was more important than
being president you often hear people
talking about if we had to do this all
over again the same kind of people we
would not have here to sit around for a
summer and talk about how to make a
constitution out of history and all that
you agree with that well I think we're
not extraordinary they were
extraordinary they were aided by a lot
of things in the environment if you
bring out people of that ability I'm not
sure you want to overdo the demo God's
the word that was applied to them they
were able people who who came on the
scene in a moment that just opened up
and with an open moment they took full
advantage of it to do something
important I think that they were they
were able intellectually able is very
important that Madison was a reader and
a thinker and and a good person
was he a lawyer he was not a lawyer
unusual he thought about it he was tried
to get some vocation which would in the
in the 1780s he could get away from
slavery as a base of his own personal
finances because he did oppose slavery a
slave holder who opposed slavery which
is all the sudden all of Virginians were
but he couldn't need a public life
called him - he spent his whole life in
public life and he was never I never had
any other vocation was Alexander
Hamilton boy yes he was of course an
important John J Don J George Washington
George Washington oh let me ask you
about it's not all lawyers it's almost
all you write a lot about slavery let me
ask you a loaded question
if James Madison was against slavery and
he did write a lot about it why didn't
he ever get rid of his slaves because
his finances rested on that institution
would you and I if our whole family
economic situation have that base will
we manumit all our slaves I think
Madison is better than a glib
condemnation would make him and not as
good you can think of things that are
realistic that he might have done and
didn't do so I put those two sentences
together if I formulated them right I
mean if he had cared as much about
slavery as he did about religious
liberty where he really fought in just
before the period I write about for
Jefferson's Virginia statute for
religious freedom I mean he was at the
forefront that when he was out in front
of his elders and people he respected
made this alliance with this a bunch of
people the Baptist's to get the
religious freedom the Virginia statute
for religious freedom if he'd fought
that hard or at the Constitutional
Convention if he'd cared as much about
restricting slavery you couldn't have
abolished it I was out of the picture
restricting slavery and really a deposed
South Carolina and Georgia as much as he
opposed New Jersey and Delaware on the
small state big state things where he
almost he and Wilson and the others
almost brought the Constitutional
Convention to breaking up July the
middle of July that's some way no such
showdown on slavery when South Carolina
and and Georgia said we got we can't we
got to have these concessions but he
made the concessions so that he didn't
it wasn't at the top of his agenda to
oppose slavery and you can indict him
for that I guess he did keep the word
slavery out of the Constitution you may
say what's that that doesn't mean
anything that really turned out to mean
a lot
suppose you had had the word in there
Abraham Lincoln then and others in the
19th century when the issue of slavery
comes to the forefront can plausibly
make the case that the founders wanted
to put this institution on the road to
extinction but they saw not only saw its
contradiction to American ideals which
they all did and they say that that's
clear enough but they wanted to set it
on the road to
would be ended and the fact that that
they the documents they had used words
and slavery and so forth and they took
that out Madison one time says we don't
want this instant Constitution to
recognize property in men that's
incompatible with Republic with the
Republican government we're setting on
so they need to do some important things
on the other hand where they really had
a crunch
you left the slave trade you added that
extra eight years from 1800 to eighteen
eight and before you'd enter the slave
trade on a somebody some deal outside
the Constitutional Convention you didn't
need to and I said I think you could
have done better than they did there's a
lot of discussion in your book about
that and there's not much time I need to
go over some other things I don't want
to cut that particularly short because
it would be a very interesting program
and so you're right in the back about
sources for all this you say that he
took for granted for the purpose of this
work of interpretation not only the
revaluation of Madison but also the
larger revaluation of the founding
period and the founding fathers that
historians have been carrying on since
World Second World War why why is that
going on what's causing that that's
interesting question what caused it
I think World War two had something to
do with it there was the period of the
the earlier 20th century when you have
the economic interpretation of the
Constitution you had a kind of almost
cynical economic interpretation you
showed the correlation between economic
holdings and votes in the Constitution
constitutional convention the beards are
associated with that and others then
comes World War two and democracy around
the world is at stake and you see a a
monstrous opposition to that and you
fight this war and it brings out the
fundamental original ideals of the
nation and then a group of distinguished
historians begin to take seriously again
more seriously and put at the forefront
what they said they were doing it wasn't
that they were trying to protect their
own economic interests or something
these were people I surely James Madison
to me is a serious man young man in the
time of this book conscientious trying
hard to think what's the best way to set
up a government that will protect
liberty and last and be an effective
government put those things together
without saying what's in it for me
or and I think the this whole
revaluation says there was a whole
heritage of republicanism not only from
a long time before but also from the
Puritan revolution in England as we used
to call it in the 17th century and then
from these fellows over in England the
coffeehouse radicals who scribbled
pamphlets in the and were more effective
more had more influence in the in the
colonies than they did back home well
the American Colonials are reading that
kind of thing about republicanism and
among them would be James Madison but it
was in the air as part of the atmosphere
was this republicanism a nice historian
since world war ii have brought that all
back and shown us a frame of reference
of thought an atmosphere of thought that
all of these people worked in and james
madison very much among them for a
moment let's say someone's listening and
they're really intrigued by James
Madison they've never thought about and
they want to get into it you list all
kinds of books ralph Ketchum's book you
arrest list robert Rutland's book drew
McCoy's book all of these in the back of
your book here what do all those books
do for you and where would you go what
would you do if you wanted to learn all
you can about James Madison you'll
pardon me if I start off by saying
excuse me I'm sorry
by all means by this book you'll pardon
me but I took that for granted yes well
it's got the viewer to do that too you
got to get your book to get to bimby I
ought to go to a bookstore and and tell
them to order this from the University
Press of Virginia remember the word
Virginia and order this book the other
books I would say there's a very good
book about very different from mine in
being at the end of his life that I've
already mentioned drew McCoy's the last
of the father's which is a very
thoughtful book about the the old man
Madison the the one volume biography by
Ralph Ketchum is the best one volume and
that's just that's a
life with a certain reflection about it
but basically tells you the facts of his
life if you want more earlier there were
the six volumes of Irving Brandt would
you travel somewhere besides Montpelier
is that the well you know you can try it
you can learn a lot by trying to to
Monticello about Jefferson you can't
learn much about Madison by traveling to
Montpelier I recommend that you do it
this is a beautiful view of the Blue
Ridge and you can you can see some
things about Madison but it's not like
going to Monticello for Jefferson
because Madison didn't design the house
he the middle part of his life he didn't
live there there isn't any physical
artifact he was a man of the mind even
more than Jefferson Jefferson loved
gadgets and he did things that you can
you can show your kids you know the
Jefferson did and you can show the
architecture and he liked to play the
violin but Madison was he was a grind he
was an intellectual he was a man of
books and of thought and to do that you
have to go to what he wrote and what
people wrote about him best way to get
at James Madison is to buy a copy of
this and then the Federalist Papers read
those numbers that I said then go on to
these other books was this a hard book
to write no it wasn't a hard book to
write one side got the the boundaries I
said I'm just going to take these years
and my purpose is not a biography it's
not to celebrate Madison it's to ask the
question about the foundations of the
American nation then with the papers
printed would have been a lot harder if
they weren't all available papers of
James Madison in his fine multi-volume
Edition I pull them down I read them I
read other people and it and think about
it and it was you know it wasn't all
that hard to write and no one else has
done a book like this I don't know of
any other book like this now were there
any did you fund it
don't question me did you find anything
new well yes I did find new things I
think I put together the fact that new
to me I'm not saying it's new to the
world of thought and scholarship that
Madison combined the kind of realism
about human nature that
characteristically maybe is more often
seen by conservatives with being a
progressive being somebody in his time
was in favor of enlarging and a new
anti-monarchic olanta colonial
progressive party in the world and then
within the United States that
combination which was also RINO neighbor
by the way is a I saw that more clearly
and I think it is something that isn't
always brought out in the manner in the
literature about Madison and it's an
interesting feature I think I think it's
pretty close to the core of something
important about the United States that
combination it what party would he be
happiest in today oh gosh
can I can I pass on that I know help us
better understand what these well he's
not it he's not a utopian he's not going
to be on a left he's not going to be on
the left wing he's not going to be on a
right wing
he's going to combine he's going to be a
progressive who's realistic so where's
he going to be is he going to be in the
moderate wing of the Republican Party or
the other moderate wing of the
Democratic Party you dedicate this book
to andrew horton miller yes not as a
father to son but as one writer scholar
to another with gratitude admiration and
love who was your father this is I'm his
father my apologies I'm missing tonight
this is dedication to my son and who is
your son he is a professor of English we
said we sent him off to headstart and he
came out the other end a college
professor is going right through at the
India Indiana University in Bloomington
and English has a good young man I'm
proud of and he helped me a lot with
this book so it was I have three other
children so that I didn't want anything
invidious but in this case it was this
book was particularly related to Andrew
so I made that dedication how did he
help you with a book well he came to
Charlottesville he put things on the
computer he looked up things in the
library he served as the as the reporter
for a group the Lilly Endowment gave me
a little money to get some people
together to read chapters of this and
Andrews out there writing down what they
said and and then organize it for me and
took he was a he was a big help in many
you talk about that someday there may be
as many as 50 volumes that's right where
and are those available across the
country again yes any good library will
have the papers of James Madison there
now they just bringing out two volume
they've skipped ahead to the secretaries
of state and the and the presidents
they've worked up into well I shouldn't
say so they don't know exactly where
they are they're there in the 1790s
maybe they're through all this period
all this is now in the papers so the
things that we're talking about the
Constitution the Federalist Papers the
memos they're all there in a volume is
eight nine ten of the papers of James
Madison so that's one way to do it if
you have that patience and intellectual
interest go just read Madison himself
and the letters to Madison good thing
about these papers is they give you the
whole correspondence here's Jefferson
here's Madison read their letters it's a
tremendous project and we're almost out
of time I hate Dean bring us up you see
you point out that he was the chronicler
of the Constitutional Convention but you
say that eight others also took notes in
yes yeah those available those are
available there's a good Yale Edition
man called max Ferrand Farr Andy and
they bring it out in paperback and they
print some of these Yeats and other
delegates but none of them comparable
there they're all pieces and bits and
pieces of the report we know about the
Constitutional Convention overwhelmingly
from the pen of James Madison so he was
both a principal participant and the
principal secretary or recorder or
reporter for the Constitutional
Convention the business of may next
James Madison is the title of this book
James Madison and the founding the
author is William Lee Miller of the
University of Virginia thank you very
much for joining us I enjoyed it a lot
thank you